for its victims human trafficking is
physically and
mentally traumatizing and sometimes even
deadly
for criminal criminal gangs it's highly
lucrative the
main smuggling routes around the world
are through latin america
and the mediterranean and asia gangs
often force their victims
into prostitution or slave labor in the
service industries
in recent weeks police have been
cracking down on the 150 billion dollar
black market and the alliance against
trafficking in person says
the only way to stop it is to try to
stamp out the demand for
cheap sex dw correspondent young philip
schultz
went to italy on the trail of the
nigerian mafia
he spoke to traffickers and to some of
the women they exploited
these scenes could have been filmed at
countless industrial areas in italy
on any given night young nigerian women
working the street almost none of them
of their own free will
at rome central station we meet david
he says he was a member of the nigerian
mafia
until he witnessed the brutal murder of
a woman forced to work as a prostitute
they cut this person into pieces then
they package it so for example
if we are ten people that know the dead
body
you carry one killer i carry one kilo he
carry one killer
everybody will go and dispose it you can
never trace the person you can never
have the person again
the person is missing it's gone
one of the nigerian mafia's bases is
said to be the southern italian village
of voltorno
often a nigerian madam is in charge of a
group of young women
behind her a well-organized network of
violent operatives
smuggling young women from africa to
europe
juliet osabo arrived in italy aboard a
migrant boat
four years ago she saw first-hand how
the human traffickers and the madames
operate
they beat the girl like are you ready to
pay her the money or not
and if the guy says no i'm tired
i i don't want to do this work anymore
they continue to beat the girl
no food no water they locked the girl
inside the room
for four days until they are able to
conquer
her juliet managed to escape the
traffickers and found refuge at a
women's center for migrants
she believes most women like her fall
victim before they even leave their home
countries
smugglers lure young women to europe
with lies and promises
on arrival they're told they are
thousands of euros in debt and have to
pay it off
sergio natsaro is an adviser to the
anti-mafia commission
in the italian parliament he says the
italian state
now treats the nigerian mafia the same
as the italian mob
yes they are mafia it's under the code
law 416 b's
they have a structure like mafia so the
code of silence
violence intimidation psychological
pressure
revenge and so on and so on ex-mafia
member david says the nigerian groups
are now operating right across europe
and they all have one thing in common
violence he shows us a gruesome video of
men beating a woman
david says she refused to work on the
streets so they tortured her to death
most of them they were ghosts they are
not registered
nobody knows about them the government
don't know anything about them they are
here
they don't have document they don't have
anything so if they die
it's very difficult for the government
to know that this person has been
missing
juliet has since been registered with
the authorities
she now has a visa and a job at a local
restaurant
but she knows she's one of the lucky
ones as long as there's a demand for
cheap sex
the mafia will keep exploiting young
women and their search for a supposedly
better life will continue
to end on the streets